you can never really put your finger on
exactly what care we were going to do
they move from one place to another and
just when I think I start to understand
them they do something completely
different
so I just woke up and came outside to go
to the bathroom with Java and there's
like
a couple dozen Caribou like sleeping on
the lake right now
gotta be quiet
got to be super quiet the snow is really
crunchy right now
generally this time of year
the Caribou were all far gone
so I've been like subsisting off of
small game squirrels rabbits
there they are
it's like a fire truck yeah it's like
not really prepared for this kind of
thing to just go down so fast like I
haven't had for breakfast I haven't had
coffee I haven't done anything
the most incredible thing I've seen
it's gonna be one of the hardest stocks
you could ever put on a caravan
they're about six seven hundred yards
away from them
[Music]
basically what happened was
one of them felt uneasy and it jumped up
heard Instinct the rest of them jump up
some of them are still laying down
[Music]
they're starting to kind of going back
down a little bit so I'm just gonna let
them be at ease
that we have the best eyesight so
they're gonna think I'm a caramel
not posing
again he's my approaches let them see me
so none of them get rattled and jump up
like they just did
so if they're all just looking at me and
I'm kind of just walking at them slowly
not posing a threat they're gonna let me
walking toward them
let's go
holding the gun above my head just kind
of shows like antlers
just a little subtle things like that
encourage the Caribou to believe that
I'm just another caribou
[Music]
crazy uh stalk man I've gone like 100
yards it's freaking nerve-wracking man
try to close that Gap a little bit more
[Music]
[Music]